friends and family said their goodbyes
to nathan valencia tonight the
20-year-old died last month following a
fraternity boxing match his funeral was
held at holy spirit catholic church as
those who loved him remembered who he
was that's where we find madison
kimbrough live after attending that
ceremony madison
nathan was described as a strong leader
and someone everyone wanted to be around
a life taken suddenly as friends and
family gathered right here tonight for
him
with it being almost a month since he's
been gone it's been a really roller
coaster of emotions
and
today has shown that
you know despite a tragedy even
happening
there can be beauty found within it
nathan valencia was honored sunday
evening at holy spirit catholic church
the 20 year old unlv student died in
november after fighting in a charity
boxing match valencia collapsed after
the match and was immediately taken to
the hospital four days later he died
family and friends sat quietly inside of
the church listening to stories of
nathan his peers say he had a way of
making his friends feel more like family
his character his charisma his positive
attitude this smile that lit up every
room and it just means a lot to know
that so many more people cared about
them valencia suffered severe brain
injuries from the fight an event hosted
by the kappa sigma fraternity all meant
to raise money for the center ring
boxing a youth boxing club kappa sigma
has since been put on suspension pending
an investigation i was the first fighter
and me and nathan trained together
and
it was messed up what happened
we didn't think this was going to happen
we just did it for charity the clark
county coroner's office classified
nathan's death as a homicide and
confirmed that his cause of death was
blunt force trauma to the head the
nevada state athletic commission has
launched an investigation into the
boxing event but according to metro the
circumstances surrounding his death are
not considered criminal and no charges
will be filed
valencia was a registered organ donor
and now his organs will help at least
eight other people in need reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now